hello everyone and thank you for
choosing to attend our virtual
conference session today i'm personally
very excited about the advancements
being made in the areas of immune
oncology and cell therapy so i've been
eagerly anticipating this presentation
by our speaker
dr hongbochi received his phd from the
university of rochester and subsequently
received his postdoctoral training from
yale university school of medicine
in 2007 he started his independent
research program at st
jude's children's research hospital
where he's currently a
member and professor in the department
of immunology and the robert g
webster endowed chair in immunology his
research focuses on mechanisms of immune
signaling and metabolism in particular
how mtor and other signaling pathways
interplay with metabolic programs of
t-cell fate decisions
his laboratory has discovered the
critical importance of mtor signaling
metabolism and autophagy in the
differentiation and function of effector
and regulatory t
cells the control of t cell quiescence
and antigen triggered exit from
quiescence
as well as the regulation of autoimmune
and infectious diseases
and cancer his research also has
contributed to our understanding of the
signaling and metabolic pathways in
dendritic cell biology
and the crosstalk between innate and
adaptive immunity
more recently dr chee's laboratory
applies systems biology and immunology
approaches such as proteomics
metabolomics single cell rna sequencing
and crispr screening and integrative
network analysis
to reconstruct metabolic signaling
circuits and identify new therapeutic
targets in cancer
and other immune mediated diseases and
now having put
all of that out there for you i'd like
to hand it over to dr chi to walk us
through some of his
a presentation of some of his findings
hello everyone it's great to be here
today
and i want to thank agilent for the
opportunity
to speak today the research
program on my lab is in
immuno-metabolism
especially the interplay between
signaling pathways
and metabolic programs for the control
of
immunity and tolerance
we are particularly interested in
several
metabolically related kinesis
including m2 lqp1 and hyposignal
on the metabolic side we are interested
in understanding
cell energetic activities like
glycolysis
and updated phosphorylation to sell
a synthetic activity to build biomass
and as well as
future sensing how nutrient can impact
immune signaling so therefore consider
this
as a bi-directional metabolic signal
within this underlying thing we explore
teach biology as the main focus
and we also investigate how the cell
responses
are controlled by the antigen presenting
cell
dengue cell and the nutritional
metabolism
today discussion i'll be mainly focusing
on our work
in t-cell immunometabolism first i'd
like to give an overview of
our research especially our more recent
approaches that rely upon the
integration
with system analogy then i'll be sharing
with you
two stories one on t-rex cells and the
other
one on cd cells and also the role of
this
you know metabolic pathways in
immune responses and anti-tumor immunity
metabolism as we understand is a
fundamental requirement
of all living cells but instead of
simply serving as housekeeping function
metabolic activity
are actively regulated for example for
proliferating cells or tumor cells
they will highly engage glycolysis even
in the presence
of abundant oxygen therefore this
phenomenon
is also known as aerobic glycolysis
of warwick effect
for activated t-cells partly because
their massive rate of proliferation
is not surprised that they will
upregulate
glycolysis as compared to naive t cell
however a number of years ago in
collaboration with steph green group who
had this somewhat
surprising funding that not only its
black house is
upregulated upon its activation it is
differentially regulated when iet cells
develop into effector cells each one
teaches to achieve 17 cells
compared when they differentiate it into
induced t-rex cells and we further show
that the 217
differentiation is partly dependent upon
glycolysis
and the transcription factor efron alpha
so highlighting the important role of
metabolism
in cell phase control
shown at this nice review from our peers
metabolic pathway has been identified in
multiple
stages and multiple cell types involved
in t
cell biology as a matter of fact
metabolism
is essentially involved in every aspect
of ketology
starting from thermosite development to
prefer t-cell activation
and then when for the activity cells to
transition into
this effector subset a regulatory subset
of
other to differentiate into memory cells
in this recent review in nature review
technology
we described several of these
intracellular metabolic programs
including the glycolysis mitochondrial
metabolism and lipid synthesis for
instance
we also highlight the importance of the
control of metabolism
by the surface receptors
and this nutrient transporters
this is also depend upon the interaction
and crosstalk
with between t cells and other cells
such as synthetic cells
among the central regulators of immuno
metabolism
is anto antois kinase
is got a name from the initial discovery
of the
uh immunosuppressant repromising their
and therefore i'm to stand for
mechanistic target
of repromptors function through one of
the kindness complexes
i'm top one that can be defined by the
molecule rapture
i'm talk to and the richter molecule as
the
adapter and first option
many of the option
molecules are important to control m2
activity either positively or negatively
a unique feature of m2 especially on top
one
activation is its ability to integrate
multiple upstream signals including
growth facts
boost factors immune signals
and nutrients
over the past few years my lab has been
actively investigating the role of
amateur
in t-cell biology on the one hand we're
particularly interested in
how amateur control t-cell questions
is activation and fit decisions
on the other hand we're also interested
in how until
signaling contributes to t-rex cell
biology
well i would like to draw the metabolic
program as linear arrows and
simple cartoons when in reality
metabolism
functions as highly complex metabolic
network
with extensive stock feedback
with forward loops and metabolic
adaptation
so therefore we feel studying
one molecule at the time is no longer
sufficient
and system level knowledge
is essential to integrate the
information
for better a logical insight
system now you prefer to use the large
data set
and unbounce approaches to integrate
the uh knowledge uh the biological
information
and so in this case um
of course this rely upon the profiling
of metabolomics transcriptomics and
other
omics at the both the population level
or single cell level but more
importantly is the integration of such
information that is critical to gain
biological insight so
as a matter of fact there's increasing
appreciation
of the power of combining the system
approaches
and the reductionist of one molecular
time approaches
to dissect complex biological traits
so therefore in the next few minutes let
me just show one example
of how my lab is combining system
analogy and reduction
reductionist approach to understand
mechanism
of the metabolic activation in
t-cells
t-cells as we know can be largely
divided into the question or non-present
cells
but isn't t cell they are very small
they are in the tissue cell uh phasor
cell cycle
and also they use mainly the activating
metabolism from their
antigen energy source
but once t-cells receive
anti-stimulation they grow
the upper regulate glycolysis as i
mentioned
and also they have a unique anabolic
metabolism what's driving this
transition
from naive to activate t-cells has
remained
unclear but it's a long-standing
interest in my
life as shown
by this uh recent cover of
nature review technology is interesting
for us to understand how we can wake up
t-cells
how we can we cut naivety cells through
tuning
of metabolic processes
our journey in this area started when we
made a t-cell specific mount called
tc1 the tumor suppressor
and we found that t-cell diffusion in
tse1
have increased cell size activation
markers
and cell cycling suggesting that they
have lost
their maintenance of cell crisis
as a consequence the cells tend to
undergo apoptosis
mechanistically this due to the average
activation
of m talk 1 suggesting that
m type 1 need to be actively suppressed
by tfc 1
to enforce the ut cell crisis
and immune homeostasis
based on this observation we must ask
what's the function importance of mtor1
activation upon engine stimulation
therefore we generated mice efficiently
in
raptor or mp1 victor or m top 2
or both and challenge those t cells
specifically non-combines
with listeria infection we found that
rapid deficiency essentially abrogated
under specific t-cell responses upon
listeria infection in contrast
richter or m-2 deficient showed only a
modest
effect in response to the shear
infection
so therefore highlighting the critical
importance
of antagon activation in driving t-cell
priming
and anti-stimulation-induced acid
from questions based on this observation
we were interested in understanding the
additional
pathway and the signaling circuits that
are important to drainage user exit
from questions so therefore we
timber with dr jimmy as injured
and the proteomics profiling
of naivety cells are tsa stimulated
at different time points we did the
whole protein and phospho-protein
profiling followed by
network analysis of the smartaromics
data
this led us to identify several
mitochondrial
pathways and important to dry testos
so therefore although glycolysis
is upright related upon under
stimulation remodeling
of mitochondrial pathways is critical
to mediate the exit of
t cell from quiescence
based on both this genetic and
productivity study we proposed the
following model
to propose the six hallmarks of naivety
exit from hyacinths including the
cell cycle entry cell growth
the sufficient signaling anabolic
metabolism
nutrient optic and the reprogramming of
mitochondria
function with antarct 1 as essential
player
to coordinate extracellular events
and intracellular metabolic
reprogramming
moreover we can apply this principle of
the immune pysons and activation to
other contacts
including the t17 responses and we
can show that m2 is important to
uh to direct the two
effects of t17 cell either the
question the stem-like suffix or
the terminal differentiated teach one
like
t17 cells
moreover we are interested in
understanding the how
t-cell priming and his active
compassions
can be directed by the signals from the
knitting cells
and we show that for example the hero
of people signaling immediating cdc one
activity to drive t-cell priming
so with this brief summary of our work
in system menology
let me start to focus on our next story
the t-rex and the nutrient sensing and
signaling regulatory t-cells
as we know are powerful cell types for
immune suppression
regulatory t-cells or t-rex are
important
to inhibit autoimmune responses
under steady state lack of which would
result in the development of
autoimmune diseases but on the other
hand
t-rex cells are major barrier to
effective
tumor immunity and tumor immunotherapy
now all t-rex cells are created equal
in the anterior cell have discrete
activation
profiles the resting of the
central t-rex cells and also known
sometimes known as
the arteries fasting of sinful t-rex
upon energy stimulation they can develop
into the effector t-rex cells
also known as atrac or e-t-rex cells
and this cell can further uh
populate the non-line for organs
known as t-shirt-specific atrexas
our work in this area is partly because
our
initial funding that's surprising at
that time
because uh although m2 has been
generally considered as a net regulator
of t-rex cells
we were surprised to find that when we
knock out anto
one or rapture molecule from t-rex cells
mice i form inflammation is highlight
a critical positive role of unpopular
in programming t-rex function and
mechanistically we show that
m2 is important garnet
the t-rex cell proliferation and their
uh mobile activation of the mobility
pathway
in driving the expression of t-rex cell
effect molecules
and all together contributing to
programming
the t-rex suppressive function
this data highlight the critical role of
m2 as a party regulator
but what we ask is more better
today addresses this question we now
call p10 which is critical net regulator
of
m2 and we found that mice
uh with t-rex specific loss of putin
a lupus-like symptom
and this is because p10 is important to
keep
ample especially i'm talk too in control
and when the t-rex are loose pten
they become destabilized and the 5v3
expression
is also dampened so therefore
p10 is critical to keep
track function intact
based on this data we showed that either
too little i'm talking
uh either too little empty activity as
shown by the raptor or amazon alpha
or too much m2 activity as shown by
p10 or atg7 knockout
in either case it's detrimental to t-rex
mediated
immune tolerance therefore we come up
with this model
showing the it's a deluxe principle to
explain
i'm told signaling in t-rex cells as
shown here
i'm talk one or i'm talk two and either
uh too much or too little of these
activities
is effective for two
uh in regulating t-rex have function
and their lineage stability
having this funding we are also
interested in understanding
how this i'm told activity regulated
as shown by this diagram from
microphone a couple years ago this
option regulation is a highly complex
process this island can work from
microphone there is other than
have mapped multiple molecules
uh some of them are neutral sensors to
activate
i'm talk 1. this option signals is very
little information
uh in t-cells or t-rex cells
and so for us um many of them actually
identify in the
cell that may not necessarily function
in
t-cells for example we show the ltb-1
function
it's important for t-rex cells but it's
a through a ampk
or mtor independent process
therefore we are quite interested in
understanding all these upcoming signals
uh
involved in uh activating uh or
inhibiting
mto activity here you can just we can
just focus on this two group
of small g protein the right symmetry
protein
or the wrapped racks multi-proteins
as well the nutrient sensors because
argentine
leucine and glutamine has been shown to
be important
for antoine activation this project
hoshi and the niko very talented
following black
challenge
we first studied the law of amino acid
which are the classical signals to
activate
m2 here we compare the ability of naive
t cells
and t-rex cells for their responsiveness
to
an amino acid stimulated until
activity at strongham here by the
phosphorylation
of s6 as you can see naive tissue has a
low baseline
until activity which does not get
much upper regulated upon amino acid
stimulation
in contrast t-rex cells have a higher
a little bit higher baseline and total
activity
but this can be further up regulated
upon amino acid stimulation
we further show that this increased
until activity is associated
uh by the higher expression of certain
amino acid transporters
on t-rex cells compared with the nail t
cell
this includes c98 which can transport
leucine and also src7a1 which can
transform
argument
moreover we stimulated resting t-rex
cells
with cd3 c28 and l2
overnight this basically will drive
t-rex start to be activated
we call them tcr tcr-activated
t-rex cells or a-t-rex cells or
simplicity
we found that this atrax cells compared
with resting t-rex cells
have higher expression of these nutrient
transporters those amino acid
transporters
also the atrax cell have much higher
intracellular levels of multiple
amino acids and also another surprise
this tcr stimulation also results in a
strong induction
of antique white in
in 80 red cells given all this
information
we next designed as experiment to screen
for
which type of feminizes are important
for
atraxis this and we use the biolog
this uh nutrient screening system
each of the well contained a single uh
amino acid or a combination of amino
acid
and then we use this overnight activity
t-rex cell as our
cell capital screening and you can see
here we found that
as a surprise the nutrients that are
able to induce
higher um activity they all contain
arginine
this arginine with another amino acid so
highlighting
probably actually has an important role
in
i'm talk one activation we upon this
information when we did uh following uh
the following validation experiment
first we stimulated this atrax cell with
different
amino acids of some of the different
amino acid combination
and we found the partnering has strong
effect
to up regulate and top one activity
and also arginine plus loose losing
also has further ability to
upregulate i'm top one on the other hand
the glutamine although has been shown to
be able to upregulate
until in other cells we do not find a
strong role
for in this system in the this system of
the
activated t-rex cells
one of the mechanism for i'm talk to be
activated
is its translocation to location so
therefore we measured
whether amino acids had a low in this
process
in t-rex cells as you can see without
amino acid stimulation
the hemp tool the red color or
acetone the green color are largely
discrete
but with amino acid stimulation the uh
proportion of them could look like has
been shown by the
colloquialized yellow signal well
stimulation with interleukin-2 cannot do
cells so therefore highlighting a
specific role
of amino acid in driving enter
translocation to lysosome
having shown the importance of amino
acids
especially arching in this process we
next study
uh user to do the reverse experiment
we have a t tyra star activated with
full amino acid
then we deprive of single amino acid
we found that preparation of arginine
alone was able to
substantially down regulate and tore
activity
and also declaration of leucine can also
have effect although the effect
the tongue regulation in fact is less
profound compared with acne
on the other hand again glutamine
preparation had no
strong effect and this
important of argentine or losing
uh m type 1 activation can be also
appreciated in vivo
in that the mice have the losing diet or
arginine diet
and uh are found to have reduced
anti-dependent
expression of this ctr4 and icos
on t-rex cells so everything together we
conclude that
arginine and leucine are the major
regulators of antoine activity
in t-rex cells
let me show this information with next
step in the interplay
between this amino acid signal and the
tcr signal
because after all tcr signals are known
as
the signal one the most important signal
to drive
his activation and also include
including
i'm talk 1 activation so here we did
this experiment
we stimulated herox cells with
tcr then in the absence
of presence of amino acid
we found that the tcr is able to
activate
i'm talk 1 only in the presence
of amino acid well when the t cell
received tcr signal without amino acid
or with amnesia uh washed off
their ability to activate
m top one is essentially abrogated
so that's suggested
the importance of amino acid
to enable tcr dependent and top 1
activation
so we also call this a row of licensing
rule
and this license syndrome by amino acid
can be also evidenced
by the examination of the
tcr dependent activation events
basically after overnight stimulation
with tcr there is upper regulation on
cd7
the surface molecule is part of the
activation events
and also there's the extensive increase
in cell size but we found that when
t-rex cell are stimulated with tcr
without amino acids
this activation wins were greatly
reduced
so therefore we conclude that amino acid
has its licensing role
to support tcr dependent until
activation
so and also going back to this cartoon
we showed the
especially in this process acting and
losing are critical
for glutamine does not seem to seem to
be so
having this information we next accepted
the function
molecule and can link the amino acid
to the activation of vampire here we
first focus on the rack a rack b
this much proteins and we obtained the
flux mice from konyang bankrupt at ucsd
and made the cd4 free uh conditional
narcomas
as you can see here the y caps uh t-rex
cell from this mice
can respond to either the uh
arginine leucine uh or the the full
cocktail of amino acids are upregulating
mp1
but this ability was greatly lost
in red a b narcotic t-rex cells
and also using sea horse by analyzer we
found that the
upon tcr stimulation the the oxygen
consumption rate
and the equilibrium rate are also
both greatly reduced in t-rex cells
lacking a recovery therefore
the reg a and recovery are important for
antoine activation
are driven by tcr and analysis
stimulation
to further understand the critical role
of this molecule
in t-rex cell biology in vivo we
generated
a separate narcotics by crossing this
flux allele
with 53 allowing us to deplete this
molecule in t-rex cells specifically
and we found that in this case the mice
with t-rex specific knockout rapid and
red b
you have the systematic
inflammation as shown by the splenium
and also the increased lymph node and
also ultimately the mice will die from
inflammation as you can see there's
extensive infiltration
of leukocytes and immune cells in
multiple organs
including colon liver and the lung and
also between these two
molecules these are the homolog molecule
this two small t
protein we found that the right a
deficient
mice in fact also developed a fatal
disease but as a later
uh concept for the rack b non-carbon
mice
have no substantial phenotype
so therefore this gives us the
opportunity to study the role of this
pathway in t-rex mediated and the tumor
immunity
to listen we uh challenged either the y
type or the right
a single number mice with the mt38
transparent material model
as you can see the reggae t-rex
narcotics
can show much better ability to control
tumor growth
this is also consistent with the single
cell rna
stick analysis of the published dataset
and show the increase on top one
activity in t-rex cells
therefore the enhanced anti-1 activity
interact cells
are important control the terac mediated
tumor tolerance and in absence of this
pathway
the antarctic immunity can be increased
i've been shown the role of rack a
racquet beeps multi-protein we also
study
the wrap the other branch of this multi
proteins
here uh we found again we
can only get the uh uh
profound immune phenotype we delete both
this uh molecule that molecule which has
been well studied
in t cell but then we also found indeed
there's a
quite extensive genetic requirement in
that we have to both elite both the rack
and the uh the rap2 molecule
to uh drive the this loss of the
t-rex phenotype and also the to drive
the mice
to early lethality suggesting the wrap 1
and web 2 a redundant regulator of t-rex
function in vivo
and in data functional here we've also
established importance of
rap to link amino acid
derived signal through the
tsc complex which is negative regulator
of
wrap function so therefore all together
we conclude that right a b
and rep one two mean these amino acids
induce ample activation
but i'm amino acid especially archangels
are crucial to drive and license pcr
dependent
until activation
in the next 10 or 15 minutes i'll switch
gears
and discuss our work on metabolic
reprogramming
of cdt's immunity in the tumor
microenvironment
as we know human microenvironment is
one's most
complex biological system it involves
highly interconnected
cell cell communication networks
as well as the involvement of nutrients
hypoxia and
metabolites as signaling mediators
tied into this complexity is intricate
and poorly understood
metabolic network which is difficult to
study
through conditional approaches
jung wei and lily along two talented
fellow in slab
decided to take this challenge they
asked
can we reprogram t-cell metabolism to
improve
adaptation therapy for cancer using
functional genomic
approaches another approach
is food principle screening
to this end we develop a book's
christopher library
in collaboration with john champlain
which allows us to target all the known
metabolic enzymes
transporters and regulators a total of
over 3000 genes
altogether around 20 000
rnas of transducing the put a metabolic
library into tumor-specific t-cells
we pack them into tumor barium ice
and then isolate tumor infiltrating t
cells
some days later the idea here is
if we have target a major macro
regulator of t cell antitumor immunity
then those t cells should be enriched
in the tumors microone
and others help us with the biphemetic
analysis although in this case
the result is so clear because
all topically the dna are targeting one
gene
and the 1g only that's known as reckless
1
which is rna binding protein with rna's
activity
in our validation experiment he said
deficient in reckless 1
can be enriching the tumors a little
time
by hundreds and also even thousands
votes
and they show much better persistence in
vivo
associated with this better persistent
and function
drug is one t cell shown markedly
improved
therapeutic efficacy in the adult cell
therapy for basis over melanoma is a
regional model for our christmas
training
and also more important is it shows
highly improved
efficacy for the uh
brl that is proceding 19 as a circuit
antigen
you have car t cell clinical model
this is in collaboration with dr geiger
and the wing king jim so therefore
lots of dragon one reckless one can
markedly improve
efficacy of adaptive piston therapy
at the magnesium level pizza
differentiation state
is a known key determinant of antitumor
immunity
and the conventional thought is t cells
with
self uh renewal and stimulus features
have better persistence under
therapeutic efficacy
but this is at the cost of reduced
effector of cell killing function
in particularly in particular recent
studies reveal tcl one positive
progenitor like t cells as critical for
sustaining
anti-tumor responses
to understand how the better persistence
of reckoning is one narcotics
cells is uh regulated we did a single
cell only sequencing analysis
in collaboration with gm and tracy
in this case we found that
the in the absence of wrecking someone
which is
showing this bring uh this orange color
on the left side
those cells showed much higher uh
tcf1 expression the gene uh
including tcl one is tc7
and this can be validated by through
psychometry analysis
it can show the regulatory narcot cell
has much
higher tcf1 expression so therefore
reckless one illegiti can increase tcr1
expression
and the proportion of this tcl1 positive
returns like t cells
interestingly despite this increased
persistence
reckless one narcotic cell returned
robust effective function
actually the later stages of tumor
we can produce even higher levels of
cytoplasm
and the quantum b the cytotoxic
molecules
in comparison with whatever control so
therefore although the current model
highlighted that the t-cellular
persistent
and effective function are two
reciprocal events
our data suggests that regulatory
narcotic can reprogram
tumor-specific t-cells to bend
both facials both the enhanced
inward persistent and robust effective
function
therefore we call them long-lived
effector cells
while we're quite excited about this
funding a key question still remains
how does regulation function at the
molecular level to control
tumor-specific
g-cell responses to address this
question
june and lilian did a truly chaotic
experiment
by applying second round crystal
screening the genetic rescue
of reckless one knockout phenotype so
basically the co-transduced
tumor specific t cell with is one
targeting guide rna
plus the genome-wide
physical library and the goal here is to
function
could deletion and block the reactions
while not called phenotype
this approach is feasible mainly because
we were able to take advantage of the
massive accumulation
of reckless one alcohol cell in the
tumor
because in the white house contact we
probably need many many mice to search
experiment
still we run into a problem we simply
have too many hits
and in retrospect this probably makes
sense
because deletion of many of the
housekeeping genes
would block reckons by knockout
phenotype
to narrow down to the specific target
relative to redness one we apply the
second
criteria we focus on only on those genes
that
are not upregulated in the reactions
while not cut
on its sequencing data this is in
consideration of the
functional rectangus one to negatively
control gene expression
by degrading their mrna so applying
both layers of criteria we obtain only
two candidate genes
and with the transcription pioneer
factor btf
immediately causing our attention
we validated the upper regulation of btf
in reckless renault cells into this
notion here
and more importantly code deletion of
btf
blocked the effect of regulatory macro
cell to improve
the tumor therapy so therefore
highlighting betf
at the novel reactants 1 functional
target
we first explored the molecular
mechanism by which
btf functions since betf
is known pioneer factor we did apex
analysis for prompting accessibility
assessment and we found that
many of the mitochondria genes showed up
regulation
in the regulatory knockout cells in
terms of the prompting
accessibility with the
approximately two thirds of them
reversed in the rectus one
etf abnormal concepts
consistent with this observation
mitochondrial mass
and mitochondria membrane potential
which are generally consider
associated with tissue metabolic fitness
upregulated in regulatory narcotic
and this upper regulation occurs in a
btf-dependent manner
moreover ectopic expression of
btf alone is sufficient to drive the
enhanced mitochondrial mass and the
mitochondria
membrane potential and we we can further
validate many of these
flow based mitochondria features with
seahorse analysis
of the mitochondria dependent oxygen
consumption
so we therefore conclude that reactions
1 btf access
ships mitochondrial fitness in
anti-tumor
t-cells
moreover our secondary genome-wide
crystal screening
also provides a rich opportunity to
identify genes
whose co-deletion can further potentiate
the effect of reckless one narcotic
in terms of the enhanced t-cell
accumulation in tumors
this is important because combination
therapy
is key to clinical success of
immunotherapy
and the topic here are ptpin2 and sux1
and the quick deletion of either this
molecule in the retinas one now called
background
and further enhanced under tumor effect
therefore providing new opportunities
for
combination therapy
so therefore we conclude that targeting
roughness one can reprogram
long live effector cells through the
two distinct mechanism one
is through batf dependent mitochondrial
metabolism
and the other one is reprogramming the
t7 positive
pretended like cell differentiation
and also from the primary and secondary
screening
were able to identify another target to
boost
antitumor immunity and also the
opportunities
for combination therapy
in this nature news reviews by ananda
goodrath
the night this cartoon nice highlight
the reprogramming of t-sub-state
by by reagan is one in white hep cells
the t-cells have limited
uh cytotoxic effect towards tumor but in
the absence of redness one they will
remember like t cells by reprogram and
also this
is associated with increased uh
cytotoxic t cells so ultimately the
least this leads to the better killing
of tumor cells
moving forward we are interested in
further developing
uh this approaches by a building upon
the target we identify
and using the absolute therapy
especially practice cell therapy
of to generate innovative strategy
towards targeting cancers
so this concludes the scientific
discussion of today
including this our work in system
immunology
neutral sensing and signaling in t-rex
cells and then the
metabolic reprogramming of cd g-cell
immunity
with that i'd like to acknowledge the
contribution of my laboratory
especially how she and nicole chapman
be the first discussion the project
basically the rack
and the wrap smokey protein and ml
acid sensing in chiroscopes and jungle
and living did the
christmas screening for anti-tumor
immunity
i'm also grateful for the collaboration
with
you means other other faculty
and staff at st
and also i appreciate the
collaboration with the scientists
outside uh including john dench quinlan
and jason luxery and
also one they want to acknowledge the
funding sources from ih
is including an iaid and nci
you can see we have a large group of
people everybody is so nice
although sometimes we can also be very
funny
i thank you for your time i'll be happy
to take any questions
hey uh
can you i hope that the l is working
fine we have like a small technical
problem
and thanks for the presentation it was
amazing we're gonna
go now to to listen to review some of
the questions that we received from the
audience we remember everybody that
if you want to send me questions we are
live so you can submit in our chat
and we will try to address as much
questions as possible
so the first question that i have here
is like
how credible situation in
microenvironment is important in direct
mediated regulation
sorry can i repeat the question yeah the
question is
how relative situation in the
microenvironment
is important in theory in direct
mediated regulation
oh you were actually referring to the
redux
regulation right yes it is very
uh important although we really don't
know
uh have so far uh
you know great deal of information um
we do know for example the uh when uh
it's very nice work from uh
doug brenner when they knock out tclc
which is the uh
molecule involving glutathione
metabolism and redux regulation
the t-rex loves their function so so
this is really
going to be an open area for for the
exploration
thank you okay good and the next
question that we have
is related to how is emptor
differ activity is differentially
regulated in this cell
versus other cells
right so uh since mtor is a central node
to integrate up multiple upstream
signals so it can be activated by many
of the
evolutionarily conserved pathway between
t cells and other cell types
on the other hand tissue have many
unique features in terms of their
activation
and differentiation so they also have
many contact dependent and unique
regulators one example is our work and
others
shown that lkb1 is critical for this
kindness for t-rex function but although
many other cells is uh go through
inhibition of amateur
but in t-rex cells is independent of
antoine
activator so therefore there's both
shared and
uh unique pathway involved and for
teachers we still have a lot to learn
all right thank you okay good and
i have like a personal responsibility to
that
it's about the role of glucose
continuing to empty activation
in in this t-rex so uh your server like
the effect of uh amino acid the plate
depletion on
the uh empty activity in the t-rex so do
you think that glucose is also
can have also like an effect in the in
the emptor
activity in t-rex like could be like any
combination of glucose and amino acids
starvation could be affecting even more
or like suppressing having more
suppressor activity in
40 reps sure uh it's great
so yes uh glucose does activate antoine
t-rex cells and also other t cells
what's in between right what's media is
glucose
induced i'm told activation is unknown
so what's that still uh will be an
interesting area for further study
so uh right again and that's why also we
can we don't know much
if we compare you know as a console we
also don't know much if we compare
um glucose with
amino acids in terms of the intermediate
molecule mediating um to activation
right and i have another related
question here
so is the effect on amino acid
starvation on
emptor regulation in cd4 or cd8
dissolves similar to what is observed in
t-rex
i think it's um yes and no
in a way because if we compare let's say
naive
c4 or they are in a way
in less activated state compared with
resting t-rex cell that's why the t-rex
have a higher baseline amtrak activation
however after anti-stimulation all these
different cell type will up regulate
uh i'm told so that's consistent with
idea
i'm toy is a signal integrator
and for this different type of t cells
thank you okay so we have here one more
question and
let me check the ones we already went
yeah so how is
regna a is at one activity regulated in
cd8
t cells um
actually similar almost like a similar
not similar like analogous to amtrak
activation redness one is such a
powerful molecule it's a powerful
molecule to program cd t cell function
so therefore the uh this multiple
pathways
can activate or inhibit reckless one
activity in cd8
reckons one of you know t cell in
general
reckless one can have the regulation at
the mri expression level
or at the uh uh
can be also phosphorylated uh for
example shown by others
by iq so we found in the uh
tumor in filtration cd cells actually is
the the rectus
activity is different from the uh the
peripheral or the overall
like uh um like the
t-cell in the peripheral and in that
case because we show that
the tumor antigen plays an important
role in modulating
recognition recognize one activity and
also recognize one dependent
gene target so that's quite a
fascinating molecule study further
the upstream regulators thank you
okay and i have a question here perhaps
like
the um i don't understand the question
but perhaps you can understand that
it says is this so effective more than
diesel i guess that is asking like if
this is
this there is any effect of this
enteroregulation in b
cells yes i mean i'm so it's also
but it's very important for b cells
there's a nice study from multiple
groups
including for example mark busby just
highlight the critical role of
mtor activated you know
function and activation in b cell
responses
and b cell function so it's equally
important
uh you know in t cells and b cells
thank you okay good so we are reaching
this hour of our
presentation i will ask the last
question and then like for the spirit
for people to send me questions and we
didn't have time to address
we will uh send a question to dr hamachi
and he
he will probably like be able like in
the next weeks to it
to answer directly but the last question
is like um
oh i love the question but did you find
uh any effect of expression
irg1 with regnaze one
no we don't know that yet that's the
interesting question
but we haven't found that link
okay great well thank you very much for
all the our audience thank you very much
for your presentation and i will
we can you can join us in the i went
with our next speakers
during today thank you very much all
right yeah
thank you so much everyone great talk
all right thank you thanks for tuning in
bye bye
you